the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi Alexa today is on the one hand
deceptively simple on the other hand
deceptively hard that from a certain
point of view to talk about the
equations of lines and planes is first
of all a topic that many people say I'm
not interested in studying geometry when
are we going to get back to calculus
this is very analogous to our problem of
part 1 in calculus if you recall where
we started with analytic geometry and
the question came up why do we need
geometry when what we really wanted to
study was calculus and the idea of
graphs played a very important role in
calculus we found out for example also
that the relatively harmless straight
line was a rather crucial curve namely
given any curve no matter how random in
the plane provided only that it was
smooth we were able to approximate that
curve by a sequence of tangent lines to
various points and in a similar way one
finds that planes will do for functions
of two real variables what the equations
of lines did for functions of a single
real variable which I say we'll talk
about that in more detail as we go along
the other nice part about this lesson is
the fact that we can now take some of
our vector properties that we've learned
from the past lessons and Hipp what I
call the homerun ball once and for all
now finish off what we've started and
that is in the study of
three-dimensional geometry the crucial
characteristics are those building
blocks called lines and planes and by
finding convenient recipes for
expressing lines and planes will be most
of the way home as far as using this
material is concerned again we'll hit
mainly the highlights today the
remainder of the material will be
covered I hope adequately between the
text and the exercises at any rate then
the lesson today is equations of lines
and planes and to refresh what I just
said before the little ratio planes are
two surfaces what lines are two curves
that we can approximate curves by
tangent lines we can approximate smooth
surfaces by tangent planes now what we
would like to do is go back to Cartesian
coordinates and find the equation of a
plane the first question that we ask
before we even use a car any coordinate
system is just how much information do
you need before you can determine a
plane well one way we know of is to know
three points in the plane another way is
analogous to the line case where to the
terminal line you needed a point and a
slope one way of determining a plane is
to know what a point in the plane and
the direction of the plane and one way
of getting the direction of the plane is
to fix a normal a perpendicular to the
plane no was the approach that we're
going to use is let's suppose that we
know a point that we want to be in a
plane and we'll call that point p0 will
denoted generically by x0 y0 z0
and let's let capital n denote the
vector AI plus BJ plus CK which is
perpendicular to a plane okay
so we're given a vector perpendicular to
the plane we're given a point in the
plane and now in Cartesian coordinates
we would like to know the equation of
the plane and as we do so often we
simply come back to a little diagram
here that will utilize vector geometry
what we say is okay here's a little
diagram here
his p0 in the plane his end normal to
the plane now we pick any point P
whatsoever any point in the whole world
whatsoever as long as long as it's in
space three-dimensional space and what
we say is what does it mean for the
point P to be in the plane well in
vector language for the point P to be in
the plane I think it's rather obvious
that p0 p had better be perpendicular to
n on the other hand in dot product
language what does it mean to say that n
is perpendicular to P Zero P that says
that the dot product of N and P Zero P
must be 0 now just to economize space
let me utilize the notation that we've
talked about in the notes
and in the exercises where in Cartesian
coordinates I'll abbreviate a vector in
IJ and K components just by writing down
its components in other words let me
abbreviate n by a comma B comma C which
stands for AI plus BJ plus CK etc notice
the beauty now of our Cartesian
coordinate system and is the vector
whose components are a B and C what
about p0p well that's the vector whose
components are X minus x0 y minus y0 and
z minus z0 that beauty of cartesian
coordinates again consequently i want
the dot product of these two vectors to
be 0 but in cartesian coordinates we
know that the dot two vectors we simply
multiply corresponding components and
add and that results in what a times X
minus x0 plus B times y minus y0 plus C
times Z minus Z 0 equals 0 by the way
each of these steps is reversible
meaning that under these given
conditions the point XYZ is in the given
plane if and only if this equation here
is satisfied another way of saying that
is what if we if a b c x0 y0 and z0 are
given constants then a times X minus x0
plus B times y minus y0 plus C times Z
minus Z 0 equals 0 is the equation of
the plane which passes through the point
x0 y0 z0 and which has the vector AI
plus BJ plus CK as its normal vector and
perhaps the easiest way to illustrate
this is again by means of an example let
me simply write down a linear expression
I'll write down 2 times X minus 1 plus 3
times y plus 2 plus 4 times Z minus 5 my
claim is that this is the special case
where a B and C are played by 2/3
and for respectively x0 y0 and z0 are
played by one negative two and negative
five the same thing as in our previous
study of ordinary two-dimensional
geometry remember that the standard form
of our equation uses a minus sign
consequently to use the equation where
we see y plus two we should rewrite that
as y minus -2 and what we're saying is
that this equation is then what it
passes through the point 1 minus 2/5 and
has as its normal the vector 2i plus 3j
plus 4k actually this is not a very
difficult concept
once you try a few examples and see
what's happening over here by the way
before I go on I just want to make a
note that I'm going to return to later
on notice by the way there is nothing
sacred about the right-hand side of this
equation being 0 notice that somehow or
other the really important factor was 2x
plus 3y plus 4z in other words notice
that the other terms led to a constant
which could have been transposed onto
the right-hand side of the equation and
that somehow or other I can change the
constant but if these multipliers in
front the 2 3 & 4 stay the same so you
notice what I'm driving out here no
matter how let me go back up here for a
second no matter how I change X 0 y 0 Z
0 whatever plane this is it still has AI
plus BJ plus CK as a normal vector what
I can change is what point the plane
passes through in other words somehow or
other if I leave a B and C fixed but I
vary X 0 y 0 Z 0 I generate a family of
parallel planes and that can be state
restated somewhat differently well I
guess if it wasn't somewhat differently
that wouldn't be called restated with it
let's just note this way for fixed a b
and c ax the equation ax plus b y plus
cz
equals D so you forget about the zero on
the right hand side let D be an
arbitrary constant what I'm saying is
that this equation is a family of
parallel planes and why is it a family
of parallel planes because every plane
in this family has as a normal vector AI
plus BJ plus CK AI plus BJ plus CK okay
the second point I would like to
emphasize about the equation of our
plane is that it's called a linear
equation meaning and I don't know why I
suddenly switch to small letters here
but that certainly doesn't make any
difference with ABC and D is constants
observe that ax plus B y plus C's equals
D is what we call a linear algebraic
equation in the variables x y and z
namely each one appears each variable
appears multiplied only by a constant
and we add these things up and notice
that in a way a plane should be linear
meaning there's no curvature to a plane
once it's fixed in space and this sort
of generalizes the idea of the line
remember the general definition of a
line was of the form 1 ax plus b y
equals a constant that was a two
dimensional linear equation the plane is
a three dimensional linear equation and
one of the subjects that were returned
to later in the course but I just
mentioned it in passing now is that even
though you can't draw in more than three
dimensional space if you have 15
variables you can certainly have a
linear equation in fifteen unknowns and
the interesting point in calculus of
several variables is that even when you
run out of pictures when you can't draw
the situation the linear equation plays
a very very special role in the
development of calculus of several
variables analogous to what a line does
for a curve in the case of one variable
and what a plane does for a surface in
the case of two variables what I want to
emphasize though also and we'll come
back to this in very short order is that
a plane has
two degrees of freedom meaning what
that in a plane observe that given the
linear equation you have what one linear
equation and three unknowns
it requires that you pick two of the
variables before the rest of the
equation is determined in other words if
given X plus 2y plus 3z equals 6 if I
say let X be 15 notice that I have what
15 plus 2y plus 3z equals 6 which gives
me one equation in the two unknowns y&z
that two actually
uniquely fix anything I must specify
what two of the three variables are in
other words in this equation I can
choose any two of the three variables at
random and solve for the third by the
way if anybody is having difficulty
understanding the difference between the
six being on the right hand side as we
have it now and the zero as we used it
originally notice that we can very
quickly find a point which passes which
is paint plane passes through for
example among other things just set y
and z equal to 0 in which case X is 6 so
certainly one point in this plane is 6 0
0 what is a vector perpendicular to this
plane it's the vector 1 I plus 2j plus
3k so using the standard form we could
write what x minus 6 plus 2 times y
minus 0 plus 3 times Z minus 0 equals 0
notice by the way that algebraically
these two equations are equivalent but
that in this form this tells me what
this specifies a point that the plane
passes through namely what this is the
plane that passes through 6 0 0 and has
the vector I plus 2j plus 3k as a normal
by the way you could do this in
different ways some person might say why
couldn't you have transposed the 6 over
here then taken 3z minus 6
you see one tool an x and y be 0 and
solve this equation and get that Z
equals 2
in other words isn't 0 0 2 also a point
on the in the plane and the answer is
yes it is and you could have written the
equation now is what X minus 0 plus
twice Y minus 0 plus 3 times Z minus 2
equals 0 that would be what the equation
of the plane that pass through 0 0 2 and
had as its normal I plus 2j plus 3k of
course what happens is that 6 0 0 and 0
0 2 belong to the same plane I mean
that's another thing to keep in mind
here that the plane that we're talking
about passes through more than one point
so x0 y0 z0 can be played by an infinity
of choices at any rate let's let that go
now as the equation of our plane and
let's talk now about the equation of a
line that's a plane let's talk about the
equation of a line how do we determine a
line in two-dimensional space we said we
needed to know a point on the line and
the slope and another way of saying that
is we need to know a point on the line
and we would like to know a line
parallel to the given line in vector
language what we say is ok let's suppose
we're given the line L and we know that
the vector V whose components are a B
and C that that vector is parallel to L
and at the point P 0
whose coordinates are x0 y0 z0 that that
point is on the line l then the question
is how do we find the equation of the
line L and again vector methods come to
our aid very nicely what we say is let's
pick any other point P in space alright
what does it mean if the point P is on
the line L if the point P is on the line
L since we want to use vector methods
let's simply observe that since L is
parallel to V the vector p 0 P being
parallel to V
must be a scalar multiple of V that's
what parallel means for vectors scalar
multiple so p0 p is equal to some
constant times V and let me pause here
for a moment to point out that this
constant is really a variable that
sounds awful how can a constant be a
variable what I mean of course is that P
was any point in this line notice that
the T determines the length of p 0 P and
how long p 0 P is is going to depend on
where I choose P in other words for
different choices of P I get a different
scalar multiple and by the way if I
choose P on the wrong side of p 0 as
I've deliberately done over here notice
that p 0 P has the opposite sense of V
so that T can even be negative in other
words not only is T a variable but if
it's negative it means that p 0 P has
the opposite sense of V if it's positive
they have the same sense but I'm not
going to be labeled that point what I'm
now going to do is in Cartesian
coordinates see what this equation tells
me and right away it tells me what that
p 0 P is that vector whose components
are X minus X 0 y minus y 0 and Z minus
Z 0 what vector is T times V well V we
saw had AZ components a B and C and in
Cartesian coordinates multiplying a
vector by a scalar simply multiplies
each component by that scalar so in
other words T times V is the vector
whose components are T a
T B and T C we also know in Cartesian
coordinates that the only way that two
vectors can be equal is component by
component and that tells us what that X
minus X 0 must equal T times a Y minus y
0 must equal T times B and Z minus Z 0
must equal T times C that's these three
equations here what do all of these
three equations have in common
numerically they all have the fact that
T and consequently I can solve each of
these three equations for
t namely what divide both sides of this
equation by a both sides of this
equation by B both sides of this
equation by C being very careful that
neither a B no C are 0 by the way if
they are 0 straightforward ramifications
take place that will leave for the
textbook to explain don't worry about
that part right now we don't want to get
bogged down in that but at any rate if
we now go from here to see what that
says we now wind up with the standard
equation of the straight line namely if
you have X minus x0 over a equals y
minus y0 over B equals z minus z0 over c
equals some constant e that particular
form is called the standard equation for
a straight line what straight line is it
it's the line which passes through the
point x0 y0 z0 and is parallel to the
vector AI plus BJ plus CK by means of an
example X minus 1 over 4 equals y minus
5 over 3 equals Z minus 6 over 7 is the
equation it's one equation really it's
the equation of a line which has what
property it passes through the point 1
comma 5 comma 6 and is parallel to the
vector 4i plus 3j plus 7k and by the way
I have to be very very on my god here B
there's something very deceptive here
the equation of a plane and the line are
very very much different but they look
enough alike so it may confuse you
you're reminds me of my daughter where I
get a lot of stories from was eating a
sandwich one day and I asked what kind
of a sandwich she was eating and she
said it was like a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich and I never heard of a
sandwich that was like a peanut butter
and jelly sandwich so I looked at it to
see what it wasn't was ham and cheese I
says why did you say it was like peanut
butter and jelly she says well there was
two things in it all right
look at the equation of a line in the
plane have three things in it x y and z
but to juxtaposition these let me write
down the two thing
that may look confusing let's suppose I
write this down you see what I'm doing
now what I'm doing now is I'm changing
the equal signs here two plus signs and
bringing up the denominators here see
this is a line this is a plane what
plane is this this is the plane which
passes through the point 1 comma 5 comma
6 and has the lie of the vector 4 I plus
3 J plus 7 K as its normal how can I
best explain this to you to keep this
straight in your mind well I think the
easiest way and again notice what I'm
saying see the XY z-- and Z's here the
XY z-- and Z's here which is which the
easiest way is to keep track of degrees
of freedom remember in the plane we said
look it you can pick two of the
variables at random and solve for the
third
I claim in this system in this system
here there is only one degree of freedom
the line has one degree of freedom
namely let's repeat this example so we
don't have to keep looking back to the
board here X let's take X minus 1 over 4
equals y minus 5 over 3 equals Z minus 6
over 7 and since we don't like to work
with fractions I'll pick a number that
works out nicely hey I say ok let's see
what happens when X is 9 now here's the
whole point as soon as I say let x
equals 9 as soon as I let X equal 9 this
is fixed right
in fact what does it become fixed as
soon as I do this as soon as x equals 9
X minus 1 over 4 is 2 now notice that Y
minus 5 over 3 has to equal to Y have no
more choice then if Y minus 5 over 3 has
to equal to and also Z minus 6 over 7
has to equal 2 you see what I'm saying
here this fixes the fact that Y must be
11 and that Z must be 20 in other words
the choice of x equals 9
forces me to make y equal 11 and Z equal
20 one degree of freedom and by the way
if you want to see this thing from a
geometrical point of view what we're
saying is
Eliza's line cutting through space all
right
notice that directly on that line only
one point will have its x-coordinate
equal to nine and what we're saying is
the point on that line whose
x-coordinate is nine is the point nine
comma 11 comma 20 okay one degree of
freedom again that's very very crucial
for you to see by the way I guess one
thing that bothers a lot of students is
the fact that they read this as two
separate equations they say you know why
isn't this X minus 1 over 4 equals y
minus 5 over 3 why can't I treat that as
one equation or why couldn't I take Y
minus 5 over 3 equals Z minus 6 over 7
or why couldn't I take X minus 1 over 4
and so that's equals Z minus 6 over 7
and the answer is that by itself isn't
enough but rather than give you a
negative answer let me give you a
positive one let me close today's lesson
with this particular illustration
suppose we had solved X minus 1 over 4
equals y minus 5 over 3 what we would
have obtained is the equation 4y minus
3x equals 17 this is very dangerous when
you look at the equation 4y minus 3x
equals 17 I'll bet you dollars to
doughnuts you tend to think of this as a
line rather than as a plane but the
interesting thing is notice that the way
we got this equation was ignoring the Z
coordinate of our points and what we're
really saying is let's forget about the
Z coordinate
in other words 3 for y minus 3 x equals
17 may be viewed as a line but in this
particular case it's a plane in fact
what plane is it it's the plane that
goes through the line 3 y 4 y minus 3 x
equals 17 which lies in the XY plane
it's the plane that goes through that
line perpendicular to the XY plane the
by way again if you go back to part 1 of
this course where we stress sets the
language of sets comes to our rescue
very nicely the difference between
whether 4y minus 3x
equal seventeen as a plane or whether
it's a line hinges on whether we're
talking about the set of pairs X comma Y
such that for y minus three x equals
seventeen or whether we're talking about
the set of triplets XYZ such that for Y
minus three x equals seventeen in this
particular example we're talking about
points in space in other words our
universe of discourse are the points X
comma Y comma Z not the points X comma Y
well anyway rather than to belabor this
point what I'm saying is in the same way
that this equation represents a plane in
a similar way had we equated Y minus
five equal three with Z minus six Y
minus five over three equals Z minus 6
over seven we would have obtained the
plane 7y minus 3z equals 17 so if you
don't like to look at our set of three
equations if you'd like to look at these
three equations in pairs you see if one
of these three equations in pairs
another way of saying it is this that
the triple equality x minus 1 over 4
equals y minus 5 over 3 or z minus 6
over 7 that that may be viewed as the
intersection of the two planes namely
the plane determined by this equation
and the plane determined by this
equation of course someone can also say
isn't there a plane determined by this
one and this one and the answer is yes
there is notice that whereas you have
three qualities here only two of them
are independent namely as soon as the
first equals the second and the second
equals the third the first must equal
the third okay but the whole idea is can
you now see the difference the easiest
way I know of to distinguish the
difference between the equation of a
line and a plane the plane has two
degrees of freedom the line has got one
degree of freedom and that triple
equality says as soon as you've picked
one of the unknowns
you've determined all of the others
whereas that string of plus sign says
that once you've determined one you
still have some freedom left now what
we're going to do is next time start a
new phase our vectors for the time being
what we have now done is finished at
least for the moment our preliminary
investigation of three-dimensional space
as seen through the eyes of Cartesian
coordinates at any rate until next time
goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate